advances in technology are always met
with some degree of technophobia and
villainization from the very beginning
mechanization has been perceived as a
promise and a threat talk of humans
being replaced by machines immediately
emerged alongside voices praising their
life-enhancing benefits cyborgs are
unique amalgamation of both ideas since
they directly merge flesh with tech some
of Pop culture's most iconic villains
are cyborgs but so are some of the
heroes what is it about the blending of
Mana machine that scares us but also
Thrills us
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
the impact of industrialization and
mechanization are crucial to the
Cyborg's history but that's not where
the idea began we have to go way back
stories of human automatons date back as
far as the fourth or 5th Century BCE the
Chinese philosophical tax lietza
includes mention of a play that utilized
a mechanical puppet made from wood and
leather that could independently move
its head sing and dance records of
steam-powered human-like automatons
appear in the texts of alexandrian
engineers in Egypt around the 3rd
Century CE there are also Tales of
automated soldiers protecting relics and
ancient Indian Buddhist texts in both
fiction and real life automatons were
intriguing Rarities prized for their
unusualness and ability to inspire
wonder and yes obviously cyborgs are
different from automatons but the two
have a blended cultural history a cyborg
is a living organism machine hybrid lawn
atomic ton is a machine made to look and
or act human Legends of brazen heads
bronze or brass talking fortune telling
automations modeled after humans fill
the pages and stages of the Renaissance
period
first appearing in the 12th century text
Chronicle of the Kings of England they
were often said to be powered by the
devil's sorcery or necromancy so these
disembodied heads were viewed as
monstrous Define natural order and
challenging the idea of the Soul by
raising questions about what moved our
own bodies what imbued life in a thing
in the 17th century French philosopher
and mathematician Renee Descartes
introduced the beast machine hypothesis
theorizing that the human body is
composed of mechanical processes or
motions as medicine emerged as a
profession around this time so did the
understanding of the body as an organic
machine supporting Descartes theory of
course this overlaps with the Industrial
Revolution and political revolutions
across the world in science and culture
the concept of the body was becoming
destabilized at the same time the
manufacturing process shifted from human
hands to mechanized devices new
technologies like the battery the steam
engine and later electricity opened a
world of possibilities including
artificial life while the emerging
Technologies became increasingly linked
to imagination magic and Utopia they
were also met with fear and trepidation
it wasn't until the 19th century that
the first human machine hybrids appear
in fiction technically German Gothic
author ETA Hoffman's 1814 automata has
the first quasi-human automation but
everyone knows it's a machine in his
1816 story The Sandman two men attempt
to pass off a wooden Clockwork driven
automaton as a real woman with moderate
success
Jane lowden's futuristic 1827 novel The
Mummy includes speculative Technologies
like a mirror hollow screen flying
robotic horses and labor Androids in the
form of prison guards judges and lawyers
in these texts before and after their
non-human identities are revealed these
creations are viewed with a mix of
revulsion and awe seen as unnatural and
frightening these Romantic Era Androids
reflected the cultural conceptions of
the human machine Dynamic Edgar Allan
Poe famously explored the boundaries of
the mechanical body and the human body
in His science fiction during his
writing career the United States saw
over 3 000 miles of train tracks laid
across the U.S with both the medical
doctor and machine doctor or mechanic
emerging as professions all of this
likely inspired his 1839 short story the
man that was used up which is widely
cited as the first true cyborg narrative
the tale is a satirical social mystery
of sorts a narrator tries to determine
the story behind General John ABC
Smith's great notoriety as a war hero
formidable and handsome the narrator is
horrified to learn that the general he
admires so much lost his teeth arms legs
scalp shoulder chest and eye and most of
his tongue from torture while a war
prisoner and now uses a false eye wig
cork legs and other man-made Parts
including a mechanical tongue
when the narrator sees him without his
non-organic additions as a large and
exceedingly odd looking bundle of
something he's frightened into shocked
silence so we've had humans with machine
enhancements and fiction for a couple
hundred years but it took until 1960 for
someone to Define them the word cyborg
first appears in 1960 in a New York
Times article about scientists looking
into enhancing astronauts for space
travel efficiency coined by researchers
Manfred e Klein and Dr Nathan s Klein
the article proposes development of
human and then some bodies that would
not need to eat or breathe because of
battery-powered devices built into the
body they provide us with the first
public definition of cyborg essentially
a man machine system in which the
control mechanisms of the human portion
are modified externally by drugs or
regulatory devices so that the being can
live in an environment different from
the normal one the late 1970s and 80s
were time of cultural and social
technological Pandemonium the
introduction of personal computers
portable phones fiber optics and of
course the internet challenged our
worldview and created new anxieties in a
post-industrial world existing fears of
machines taking over humans jobs and
relevance seemed even more possible and
like always popular culture exposes that
anxiety and imagines the possible
effects of digital technology positive
and negative in dystopian Android movies
like The Terminator and Blade Runner but
also more optimistic characters like the
superhero Cyborg and DC Comic universe
and ghost in the Shell's crime fighting
cyberpunk major motoko kusanaki in 1985
Donna haraway's feminist post-human text
a cyborg Manifesto declared we are all
already cyborgs she argues that humans
are chimeras of organism and machine a
reality we sit with uncomfortably
although she argues we should take
pleasure in such instability and
transgression haraway uses the cyborg as
a metaphor to challenge the definition
of human and non-human she points out
that we are already cyborgs modern
medicine has advanced to the point that
small machines can reside in the body in
what she refers to as couplings the
anxiety around cyborgs is their
perceived threat to humanity in the
physical and mental enhanced humans who
challenge the very idea of human
post-humanism is a philosophical concept
that challenges anthropocentrism the
idea that humans are the Central and
most significant entities in the world
it's all about blurring or eliminating
the boundaries between humans and other
organic and inorganic matter monsters
and the post-human are intertwined as n
Catherine Hales argues and how we became
post-human even the threat of
transformation via technology inspires
simultaneous Terror and pleasure but
that does not mean the post-human has to
be apocalyptic or anti-human but you can
probably see how the cyborg can easily
represent both the negative and positive
interpretations of post-humanism
discovery and zoology also contribute to
our modern conception of cyborgs by the
end of the 20th century the distinction
between the human animal and the
non-human animal is narrowed many
non-human animals craft and use tools
problem solve have complex languages
social behaviors and grieving practices
the cyborg then is a man-made
distinction between human and non-human
animal where artificial devices
contribute to making humans less animal
although a more radical approach is to
see the cyborg as a break in the
distinction between human animal and
machine in a post-humanist utopian
vision of connectivity among all things
where boundaries are not only blurred
but they also simply don't exist which
is both liberating and terrifying this
is why the cyborg is always made
monstrous from The Hive mind-driven
villainous Borg and Star Trek to
Marvel's Doctor Octopus or James Bond's
nefarious Dr No Evil or antagonistic
cyborgs are physically threatening with
their Divergent Technologies marking
them as the other or the bad guy in the
story even when cyborgs are the good
guys this holds true but they are
painted in a different light RoboCop
Iron Man major motoko The Bionic Woman
and others like them almost always have
some traumatic backstory or event that
propels them towards mechanical
augmentation justifying their
monstrosity Star Wars is the perfect
example both Darth Vader and Luke
Skywalker are cyborgs at least since the
end of episode 5. we spend a New Hope
and The Empire Strikes Back following
Luke's struggles and triumphs his tragic
backstory an orphan relegated to a hard
life on an unforgiving planet after his
father was murdered at least that's what
Obi-Wan tells him creates sympathy even
before his hand is cut off Luke's
artificial hand even looks organic at
first essentially his cyborg nature can
be hidden Darth Vader's Tech on the
other hand is not only on full display
it visually makes him the villain his
cyborgness isn't Justified that is not
until Anakin's own tragic history which
helped push him to choose the dark side
is revealed I must point out that this
only happens explicitly in the newer
movies released at the turn of the 21st
century when arguably attitudes towards
robotics have somewhat shifted
nevertheless all cyborgs still represent
the fear inherent in losing ourselves in
the Technologies we create cyborgs may
not inherently be monsters but we are
afraid they will become monsters our
response to them is largely driven I
think by how we want to integrate
technology into our life do we live with
technology or do we become technology
writesia includes mention of a play
Clockwork driven
the automata Matan